this is Lee J young known to the Western
world as j y Lee Jay is the grandson of
the great Lee bang chol the founder of
Samsung normally these types of people
are lazy spoiled brats but not Jay Jay
has actually done a lot to grow Samsung
in fact you could say that he's the guy
who made Samsung into the multi hundred
billion dollar Juggernaut that they are
today but this sort of wealth and power
didn't come clean it was the result of
massive amounts of corruption in fact
Jay was so corrupt that he was bribing
the South Korean president and he got
sentenced to prison twice the first was
a 5-year jail sentence for bribery and
embezzlement and the second was a 2 and
a2e sentence for bribery being the
second richest man in Korea though I
don't think you'd be surprised here that
Jay didn't end up spending all that much
time in prison but that was completely
fine the prosecution's main goal wasn't
to put behind bars but to remove him
from power and publicly exposing him did
exactly that for over 5 years it seemed
that the era of JY Le Samsung was
officially over but out of nowhere in
August of 2022 South Korean president
Yun sakol would pardon Jay and just 2
months later Jay would return to Samsung
as chairman a position that he has held
ever since now you might be jumping out
of your seat to blame president Yun
sakyo
of course he's just another bought out
politician that's controlled by the
super rich now that could very well be
true but what I can also say is that the
president did not act alone you see it
was actually at America's request that
President Yu decided to Pardon Jay so
here's the story of Jay's insane rise to
power his humiliating Fall From Grace
and his unexpected return to the
throne
taking a look back the story of Jay
dates back to June 23rd 1968 to Soul
South Korea at the time Samsung was
already a thriving business involved in
a variety of industries from grocery
exports and textiles to Insurance
security and Retail but while Samsung
was already successful they had yet to
even enter the industries that they're
most known for today Electronics and
appliances and it would end up being
Jay's father Lee Khe would lead this
Evolution making him the chosen Heir
within the Samsung family Jay on the
other hand was just a small boy during
all of this who was slowly working his
way through the school system I don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
Jay ended up attending the prestigious
Soul National University the same
University that sang Wu attended where
he majored in East Asian history he
followed this up with an MBA from Kio
University before attending Harvard
where he spent 5 years trying to get a
PhD in Business Administration
unfortunately though he would never end
up finishing and just St to the family
business which he joined in 1991
speaking of joining the family business
let's just say that he had a royal
welcome as he would join directly as a
vice president of strategic planning at
age 23 and shortly after this he would
be promoted to Chief customer officer a
SE Suite position that was created
specifically for Jay obviously Jay
largely benefited from nepotism but that
isn't to say that Jay wasn't talented in
his own right after all it's not like
all of Samsung's erors have ended up as
pivotal as Jay even though they all got
kushy executive positions and the main
reason for this is that Jay chose to
focus on the right sector of Samsung his
sister Lee bu Jin for example went down
the hospitality path and became the CEO
of Hotel Shilla a luxury Korean Hotel
chain associated with Samsung similarly
his other sister lisan went down the
philanthropy route and became the leader
of Samsung's welfare Foundation our boy
Jay however had far larger Ambitions and
he knew exactly where the future lay
Electronics this came in the form of
three separate breakthroughs starting
with memory chips 1999 Samsung would
develop the world's first one GB in N
Flash and they would follow this up with
a groundbreaking pace of innovation 2 GB
in 2002 4 GB in 2003 8 GB in 2004 16 GB
in 2005 32 GB in 2006 and 64 GB in 2007
they were basically doubling every
single year and when you combine this
rapid Innovation with Samsung's
resources power and connections I don't
think you'd be surprised here that
Samsung would end up as the king of
memory this would end up being really
important as this business is what would
eventually bail Jay out of jail but this
was just the beginning of Jay's
contributions at Samsung his next big
contribution was TVs Samsung didn't
necessarily create TVs that were better
than the competition but what they did
do was Market TVs better than the
competition they attended all these Tech
events where they showed off massive TVs
stupidly High resolutions and a bunch of
marketing gimmicks this included things
like 3D TVs curved TVs OLED CED Neo CED
and who knows what else this isn't to
say that all of this technology was just
a gimmick OLED for example is awesome
technology but what really sold this
technology was Samsung's phenomenal
marketing which has given them the
number one spot in the TV market for the
past 17 years and at the helm of all of
this was Jay but if you think that
memories and TVs are big you probably
forgot that Samsung also dominates
another industry smartphones I don't
think I even need to explain this one
Samsung has sold over 2 billion galaxies
itself and according to Samsung Jay has
made invaluable contributions to these
sectors of Samsung so it's no wonder why
Jay was next in line to take over the
company but there would be a pretty big
scare before this actually
happened in 2008 Jay's father Lee Khe
would resign from his position as
chairman normally this would be great
news Lee had just completed a Legendary
Run as Samsung's chairman and was
retiring to make way for younger
Generations right well that's not
exactly how this played out Lee didn't
resign because he wanted to retire he
resigned because he was forced to retire
you see Lee was indicted on charges of
massive tax evasion and he would end up
with a three-year suspended sentence
along with a $19 million fine this
itself was terrible publicity for
Samsung but what they were really
worried about was a potential political
crisis prosecutors were also alleging
that Samsung had bribed influential
South Cran politicians prosecutors and
bureaucrats and if this was proven in
court that would truly be a disaster
looking to avoid this Lee and several of
his Executives would resign which got
the prosecutors to back off and drop the
bribery charges but while Lee was able
to leave the situation pretty clean the
same could not be said about Jay Lee had
tarnished the family name making it very
difficult for Jay to ever take over the
company but this Duo wasn't going to go
down so easily what they had to do was
clear the family name and they were
willing to go to any length to do so
including bribing the president of South
Korea Lee miang Bach also this isn't
just speculation or something Lee miang
Bach would eventually be sentenced to 15
years in prison partially for accepting
this bribe and pardoning Lee Khe I think
it's safe to say that the former
president regretted accepting this bribe
but the same cannot be said about leeon
he in 2010 Lee Lee would return to
Samsung as chairman as a pardoned man
making the bribe quite worth it and now
that Lee was back in charge his son was
also in the good graces of the company
who would make Jay Vice chairman in 2012
as you can see these Mega companies and
their leaders have a billion different
ways to get out of any situation you get
charged with tax evasion no problem you
get charged with bribery no problem
obviously you don't want to follow their
footsteps when it comes to any of these
illicit activities
but one aspect that we can learn from is
how these companies are dealing with the
high inflation High interest rate
environment and their secret is US
treasury bills all of the biggest
companies in the world own tens of
billions if not hundreds of billions of
dollars worth of us treasury bills
including Warren Buffett and this is not
surprising given that treasuries are
paying out historically high yields of
over 5% we wanted Everyday People to be
able to take advantage of these high
yields just like these companies
companies are doing and that's why we
created Silo a modern Bond investing
platform with Silo you can invest in
corporate and government bonds all with
the protection of $500,000 in sipc
insurance and $2.5 million in FDIC
insurance so if you would like to lock
in high yields for yourself from the
comfort of your phone please consider
checking out our bond investing platform
Silo in the description below but anyway
while Lee was able to ye out of jail
time something that he couldn't ye out
of was health concerns in 2014 Lee would
suffer a heart attack and though he did
recover this event would basically make
Jay the defacto chairman of Samsung
leading us into his own foray with the
law given his family's history Jay was
probably involved in several Shady
activities over the years but the crime
that goam arrested was bribery of
another South Korean president Park Gan
it turns out that Jay had offered $38
Million worth of bribes to the
president's friends and acquaintances to
push through a merger Samsung had no
choice but to admit that they had indeed
handed over this money but they would
insist that this was merely a good faith
donation and that Jay had no idea that
these people were connected to the
president this was obviously complete
and utter BS and unsurprisingly Jay
would be found guilty of perjury
embezzlement and bribery leading to a
5year prison sentence something else
that isn't surprising is that Jay never
ended up spending 5 years in prison
after spending one year in prison the so
high court would magically reduce his
sentence to 2 and A2 years and suspend
it meaning that he was let go
unfortunately for Jay though the Supreme
Court of South Korea would end up
ordering a retrial which resulted in
another 2 and a half year prison
sentence for Jay in early 2021 by this
point though Jay had already pulled all
the strings he could to minimize his
stay in prison and all he could do was
just put his head down and serve his
sentence that was until America decided
to get
involved if you've been following the
tech world you're probably familiar with
the chip shortage that we went through
recently whether you were buying a Tesla
or a regular old refrigerator you often
had to wait several months or even more
than a year just to get your product and
the main reason for this was the supply
chain shortage and more specifically the
chip shortage on one side decided this
was great for businesses as they could
jack up prices and capitalize on limited
Supply but on the other hand they were
missing out on a lot of demand simply
because they couldn't meet the demand
not to mention all of this was making
President Joe Biden look pretty bad so
America turned to Samsung and tsmc to
fix this issue unfortunately for America
though Lee canhe would pass away in late
2020 meaning that Samsung needed a new
leader to navigate this supply chain
crisis and who better for the job than
The Prodigy son with Shady ethics j y
Lee how could they get Jay out of prison
though Easy by leveraging the largest
lobbying group in America the United
States Chamber of Commerce if you're
wondering who funds this lobbying group
well they don't disclose their donors
but some companies are transparent about
their affiliation this includes the
likes of FedEx Facebook Microsoft
Chevron Comcast Ford and fizer so yeah a
pretty powerful group and in 2021 these
guys would approach South Korean
president Yun sakol with a proposal to
solve the global chip shortage this plan
started off by getting Jay out of prison
in August of 2021 on parole just 7
months after he was sentenced for the
second time this parole however came
along with a 5-year restriction on
business activities so Jake couldn't
just immediately return to Samsung but
that was okay it was better for Jay to
lay low for a while and wait for people
to forget before returning anyway way
and that's exactly what would happen 12
months after getting released president
Yun sakol would pardon Jay in August of
20122 his reasoning was that Jay was
simply too important to the Korean
economy to be kept in jail outraged by
this part and activists would protest on
the streets but this didn't stop Jay
from returning as chairman in October of
2022 since then memor ship prices have
fallen off the cliff as much as 53%
actually in fact memory chip prices have
fallen so much that Samsung's own
profits have fallen by 95% within just
one year is this because of some strings
that J pulled or just a result of the
market naturally correcting we may never
know but this doesn't really matter for
Jay or the lobbyists because things
played out just fine for them and that's
how a convict ended up as the new
chairman of Samsung Jay may be back but
he's definitely feeling the pain of
falling memory chip prices and more
importantly the era of Peak smartphone
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
[Music]
one